foreign
talking to three parts originally I was
going to do five parts but then I read
earlier this week that I was a professor
at New York University who got fired for
trying to do uh too much in his classes
so I will I will try to keep it uh keep
it to three
um so the first part I want to talk a
little bit about the last year which has
been a very eventful year for me
second I want to talk a little bit about
the what kind of research I do in in
general about causality and third I want
to make some comments about some of the
work I've been doing with some of the
tech companies in the last 10 years or
so since I moved here to the to the GSB
and so that that part
of the talk I'm going to reflect a
little bit on what I've seen there what
I've learned there and what I think we
need to do at the GSB to to ensure that
the students here are well prepared to
be effective participants at in
data-driven decision processes at such
companies and so at a high level that
means that doesn't necessarily mean
being able to do all the analysis
yourself but people need to be
understand these analysis and they need
to be able to ask the right questions
and I'll try to
to illustrate that
so
um let me first start by by sharing with
you some of my experiences uh from the
last year and this is a particularly
nice time to do this because coming
Monday at about 2 15 the am Pacific time
the president of the royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences will again be making
a couple of calls to some some lucky
economists
telling them they've they've won their
asparagus Ricks Bank prize for economic
Sciences in memory of Alfred Nobel and
I'm giving the full name of the prize
here because although it's it's often
referred to as a Nobel Prize
it was first awarded in 1969 I wasn't
part of the original five Nobel prizes
but it's it's part of the same
organization now and they use the same
criteria but so one funny story here is
that last year in November Swedish TV
sent a crew over here to make a program
about the the lawyers in economics and
so they spent a day and a half
following me around and then a day and a
half following David cart and then half
for for Josh angrist
so out of that day and a half they
managed to uh they condense that to 10
minutes uh but but the the a key part
that include this exchange at the at the
breakfast table where my ten-year-old
daughter was asked me asked me if this
wasn't really just the fake Nobel Prize
so
but back to the to a year ago the big
the big had actually been a pretty good
week in the in the ATM men's household
my wife had had just been elected
president of the American economic
Association
that wasn't quite as much of a surprise
as
it could have been because it's kind of
a soviet-style election but there's only
one candidate um so the the
honor was more and getting nominated for
that in the first place
um but it was it was a very good thing
nevertheless and in addition earlier
that week I had I like to go back I'm
from the Netherlands originally um I
like to go biking and I I'd broken my
personal record growing up all the Honda
I had many of you have probably know
where that that is sad but I I my
previous personal record was from three
years for four years earlier so I was
actually very pleased uh breaking it I I
I think it was 24 minutes 31. so the
world records around 14 minutes I'm way
behind there but I I was I was pleased
nevertheless
but so so it was a good week then
Monday morning at 2 13 I
I got my phone rang then I when I looked
it actually turned out it had rang a
little earlier at uh at six minutes past
two and I saw that that call had come
from uh from Sweden
and so that was that was a a very
nah
nah indescribe there you go it was a
very Indescribable moment so I you know
I I picked up the phone uh and so the
interesting thing is that the call comes
from someone named Adam Smith
and so for the for for the chemists and
the physicists that may not really be
that that unusual but for the economist
that's that's really a unusual call to
get because we we associate that name
more with someone uh was a very good
Economist but we died a long time ago in
17 uh
90.
so then the
kind of pretty much the first thing they
ask is if you're actually willing to
accept the prize uh and actually I I
said well before saying that whom am I
sharing it with and it turned out of
sharing with uh with David cart that was
a former colleague of mine at Berkeley
uh and Josh angrist was a colleague of
mine at Harvard long time ago it was
actually a very close personal friend um
it was the the best man at our wedding
so I was extremely pleased to be uh
sharing with with them um and and then I
said yes I was happy to accept that then
they say wow you have about 20 minutes
before we announce this on at the press
conference I would like to you to call
in so you have get a cup of coffee
because it's going to be a big um it's
going to be a big day
as a later I talked to one of the the
people from the Nobel Foundation you get
a distinct impression that they really
like giving these prizes to people in
California and kind of waking them up in
the middle of the night and so I've seen
some more of these videos now where they
talk to these people five minutes after
they've woken them up and it's sort of
clear they're not very coherent I wasn't
very coherent in the press conference
but they they that sort of part of the
the Mystique and it makes for very
interesting uh
social media La the year before there
were two other people here from Stanford
who won the prize in economics
Bob Wilson here from the GSB Paul melgum
from the economics Department uh and
they actually live on the same street
and and Paul didn't answer his phone so
there's this video where Bob Wilson
walks over to Paul's house which is just
half a block actually
we used to live on the same street in
the early 2000s uh it's it's a very good
Street apparently yeah but so Bob Wilson
walks over to Paul and rings the
doorbell and there's a video
automatically recording this where Bob
goes Paul Paul wake up wake up you've
won the Nobel Prize and so that um that
video made a big impression on the on
the internet
um but so after that
um
very quickly actually the Stanford
Stanford media team showed up they um
they they were apparently very well
prepared kind of in general for these uh
these things showed up with the whole
team helping to handle the some of the
media increase uh taking pictures taking
videos
and they they and sending out a series
of clever tweets uh so here here are
some of the the pictures from uh from
very early that morning
there are three kids got very excited
about the the whole thing and um and
started making breakfast for the for the
Stamford uh crew
and um so here on one of the other
practice we're looking at some of the
emails coming in that my my son was then
actually managing
so we just made for a for a very
exciting
um morning and clearly Twitter is
actually a perfect medium for for this
type of um of events there there were
just a huge number of them coming in my
favorite one is that that Stanford sent
out is uh the is this one here which I
am happy to use whenever my kids are
complaining
these days
and but Sanford just did an incredible
job one of my former students uh Paul
Goldsmith I think think I'm kind of
commented at some point that man the
Stanford media team is is really killing
it um and they this is one place where
they they clearly beat uh MIT and uh and
Berkeley where angris and cart
the arm
um
what are some of the other funny things
that uh that happened that day one was
that National Public Radio kind of
following in a long tradition
confused uh causal and casual and so
they they they told their listeners that
that the part of the prize that that
Josh English and I said was for our
study of casual relationships and so it
uh
them
Susan wasn't particularly impressed
um
another thing is that at uh
at Berkeley where I I used to be there's
actually an additional uh benefit coming
from within the well price you get your
own parking spots uh now I don't
actually uh need that that here because
I we live on campus so I actually ride
my bike to uh to campus then later I
find out that in some places including
in the Netherlands they do actually give
give Reserve dedicated parking spots to
uh to know about laureates um but then
then and so as I was tempted to go ask
the the dean if I could get it at the
bike parking spot but then I found out
that um the most recent uh novel
Laureate in the Netherlands we had one
of these spots then had his bike stolen
two weeks later and presumably the the
thieves figured out that that was going
to be a valuable bike and
at least a memorable one so I I decided
to just stick with uh parking it
anonymously here in front of the the GSB
now um
second thing is that sort of since
um getting the price
a lot of things to say is that I have to
do a lot more General
talks sort of where before I was giving
a lot of uh you know I would typically
give academic talks now some of these
audiences are much more General and that
obviously creates uh
creates challenges uh and so what what
I've done kind of is what I do with most
of the challenges coming my way as
economic I sort of try to talk to people
try to find people who are experts on
this do some research on this uh and and
some parts of it have at least improved
but one of the most challenging one was
um I had to give the commencement speech
at my son's High School the graduation
he was graduating uh last year and so
that was a particularly tricky audience
so at some level it was just an audience
of one that mattered here I I obviously
the worst outcome would be if if my son
was unhappy with that but we have two
more kids at the school so I also had to
make the the other the
constituencies happy including the the
parents whom we we interact with a fair
amount as well as the the teacher so so
I was I was very worried about for that
about it for a while so spent some time
um thinking what to do there so
when I what I actually did at the high
school commencement
um was talk for a little bit about how I
thought about how I got to the the
topic for that and so I I started
describing how I went to uh Brown
University for that commencement a
couple of uh weeks earlier I gone to
graduate school then I went back for
commencement because they gave me a
honorary degree there and so at Brown I
had a chance to listen to some of the
commencement speeches there
um I know some very interesting speeches
at that commencement including uh Nancy
Pelosi but also the
actually sorry I forgot to even though I
did not get a parking spot uh I did the
get a street named after me in the
Netherlands in my in front of my old
high school so that was a that was a
again not not quite sure what to what to
do with that but it was very interesting
experience
but um
back to the servant to Brown for
commencement and so one of the
commencement speakers there was the it
was Shaggy now I had not heard of Shaggy
at that at that time and my kids had not
heard of Shaggy there but there's sort
of a group in between including most of
the teachers at my son's school who had
heard of Shaggy and so when I brought up
his name they were kind of they all
perked up because they were kind of
curious where that was going to go
and so so for those of you who don't
know who Shaggy is he sort of was a he's
a reggae artist he had a big hit in in
2000 called it wasn't me
as I started describing this and now the
teachers got very interested to see how
I would pull that off because the song
is is about this guy who's who cheated
on his girlfriend
and he goes to Shag he said what and his
girlfriend caught him and he goes to to
Shaggy he said well what am I going to
do
and Shaggy said wow just deny it
and the rest of the song sort of goes
into graphic detail about all the
evidence that the girlfriend has the
text the phone calls the videos all the
incontrovertible proof and Shaggy every
time says you know just say to say it
wasn't me
and so
um I I told the story and I said well I
was kind of
nah confused why why they saw that was
actually a good idea to kind of have
that why why Shaggy doing that song was
a good idea in this day and age kind of
just not taking any responsibility for
what you've done a completely denial of
all Truth uh sorry so afterwards I
talked to uh to Shag he said wow
who told you that was that was a good
idea to kind of send the brown students
into the world kind of with this message
of just denying all the truth and uh and
and then Shaggy said wow it wasn't me
so yeah so that actually worked worked
incredibly uh well there for the the
commencement because the teachers really
liked it and then the students were very
confused by the teachers were so happy
but they thought it must be somehow
interesting and
and so the
that went very well so let me now kind
of switch to the the second uh part
but I want to talk a little bit about my
research and as Tim said this will be on
the exam at uh at the end but rather
than than do my own version I'm going to
give you a video that uh that Stanford
recorded
um again in the early hours of uh of
October 11th uh last year a colleague of
mine uses it in one of his classes last
year and then the student said wow that
was actually much clearer than what
imman said himself so I'm not going to
attempt Faith here and so I'm just going
to play the the video here
uh my name is Carlton imbenz that's oh
it's pop again pop can you just Susan
can you take my phone actually from what
I understand like where you are famous
let's say I want to understand
from what I understand you take data and
you kind of run your own experiments
without actually running an experiment
like you you can take data and use it as
if it was your experiment yeah that's
right it's kind of you know in a lot of
cases when we try to get the answer to
important questions we do experiments
when they try to figure out if the
vaccines for covet were working did it
all sorts of experiments but in a lot of
cases in economics you can't do
experiments kind of just doesn't work we
can't say wow you go to school and we're
gonna have this whole other set of kits
and they're not allowed to go to school
yeah so so that kind of that wouldn't
work and so we need to kind of try to
tease out those things from from data
where people just make their choices and
kind of do what they they want to do
and so we kind of tried to come up with
clever ways of still teasing out these
effects and so you might like use like
Behavior things What's It Gonna what
I've done is is a lot of the methodology
kind of trying to help people understand
exactly how these method these things
work and giving them better methods for
for doing these things and so
another study that that one of the my
friends who won the prize with me uh
George Congress did was he want he was
interested in the effect of getting more
schooling getting more education on
earnings and he used the fact that
compulsory schooling laws changed a
little bit so if you're born on
September 30th you need to go to school
earlier than if you're born on October
1st of course it doesn't really make you
a different person
but it makes you get on average get a
little bit more schooling and so kind of
you use that as an instrument you know
as a way of teasing apart the
correlation and the causality and he
could see from there that the people
were kind of we stayed in school just a
little bit longer found out that they
were actually having
higher income later it's very
interesting thank you how you can take
uh like data from like things that were
completely like not like not intended
for you yeah for anything and then and
then use it to draw these like
astounding conclusions I'm Andrew and
Benz uh spelling of my first name is a n
d r e w uh I'm gonna assume my last name
is it's the same as mine
um it's okay congratulations thank you
thank you um it was a very exciting
morning yeah so I was wondering about
some of the applications of what you've
been doing because you know we've talked
about like what kinds of like what it is
but so what what might you well yeah so
you know kind of in general we were
interested in what would be you know for
social policy it's kind of important to
know what would happen if you give
everybody some guaranteed income
what would that do to society what would
this would people still try and look for
a job or would they kind of just be
happy to sit at home
because you can't do an experiment there
you could look at uh people who played
the lottery because then some of those
people are going to
win some big amount of money that's kind
of like having a basic income in fact
kind of when we the lottery we looked at
in Massachusetts
if you win half a million dollars you're
going to get a check for half a million
dollars you would get a check for 25
000 every year for 20 years
so that's kind of very much like
having a guaranteed income we kind of
looked at what happened to them did they
stop working did they retire early or
did they keep working and turned out
most of the people really just kept
working it was kind of very nice for
them to win the lottery but it didn't
really change what uh what they did it
helps kind of inform public policy and
it kind of and it gives you a credible
way of looking at what the effect is of
having having some income which would be
very hard to do otherwise all right so
I'm a little interested in making sure
that I understand this so yeah I have to
explain it I I know my stuff let's say I
want to understand
whether not having homework for math
specifically makes people enjoy it more
and so I've got my school you could
probably imagine that that would be the
case right yeah exactly I don't like
homework I do like math I don't have
math homework maybe they're correlated
so
my school
advertise itself for kids who love math
and they don't have math homework since
we need more data than just that we'll
look at the other schools in my area
Palo Alto High School and Gunn High
School both also take from the same
batch of students in in the the you know
bay area and they do have math homework
what you're saying is that I can't just
take a bunch of students from proof
school and a bunch of students from gun
and ask who enjoys math more we need a
better test group and so what you're
saying is that I should go to gun in
Palo Alto High School and I should find
students who've not only applied to
proof but gotten into proof they're
clearly kids who could have gone to prep
school but didn't and now have math
homework yeah and so so you could have
could also look at kids who kind of
didn't go to proof but were really
interested in math but it was kind of
too long a commute so they left far away
from the train station and would have
been a long bike ride or drive to the
strange station but otherwise they would
have gone and obviously living far away
from the train station is probably not
really correlated it has nothing to do
but like liking math or not you wouldn't
expect to do it yes and so and kind of
more generally there's a lot of cases
where you have you want to compare these
two groups but you're worried about them
being different and lots in other ways
you can you look for these these small
things that make people that change the
incentives uh a little bit but that do
not have anything to do
with who they are what their preferences
are
right so so it all sort of boils down to
if you wanna know whether thing a has an
effect on people you compare really
similar people like you want you want to
make them as similar as possible in all
the ways except for thing a yeah I know
and you kind of use these instruments to
kind of change this incentives to be in
one group rather than the other things
that that people don't have Choice over
so that's it's like a randomized study
exactly instead of footy that small
group it is it becomes like a randomized
study it becomes like an experiment you
get the benefits of a experiment without
actually having to run an experiment
incredible stuff clearly
thanks
[Applause]
so so now that is an example of um of
one of these these natural experiments
that Kat Angus and I got the the prize
for and I alluded to that in the in the
video
that there was one study I did with uh
when I was at Harvard with the colleague
of Manda Don Ruben and a student uh
Bruce acido where we were interested in
the effect of honor and income what
would be the effect of having a basic
income kind of on a variety of outcomes
initially actually we're interested in
the effect on on children but there were
not enough people in the the sample in
the end to do much with that so we
looked at the effect how it affected
people's labor Supply how much they they
work and so
clearly the
you can't directly
it's clearly it's a question that's
important for for deciding on social
um
policy but it's difficult to get at uh
at that directly so what what the
economists had done in the past was do
things like look at the the effect of
spousal income on individuals labor
Supply but it doesn't really work very
well if you were to come compare say men
whose wives make a hundred thousand uh
with men whose wives make fifty thousand
uh you don't see the demand with the the
high earning spouses work less than the
men with low earned exposes because
they're very different there's a there's
a lot of sort of matching these days in
merits and you know there's actually a
lot of research on that ratchetia
Harvest kind of do looking at all these
things where where the correlation and
characteristics between spouses has
gotten much higher over the over the
years and so that doesn't really work
very well people have also looked at the
effect of inheritances but again that's
that's not
even remotely random it's it's something
people often anticipate uh there may be
other transfers prior to that so what we
did here in this study was look at
people who won the lottery yeah and in
this particular Lottery a man you would
get paid over 20 years so you would
actually get regular payments for a long
time completely unrelated to
your own income to your own decisions
now then it turned out there was still
kind of some challenges uh the the
people were fairly different to begin
with the people who want large amounts
of money because of their non-response
type issues but in the end they allowed
us to get very precise and very credible
estimates of how much people would work
less
per dollar they would actually receive
and it's on the order of five to ten
cents less per dollar in some sense they
consume Leisure they use some of that to
to reduce their hours and and
have more free time
but so this is a way where earlier work
had a very hard time coming up with
credible ways of of
identifying that doing an experiment
clearly was not what was not something
feasible that would be incredibly
expensive and take an incredibly long
time but data out there would allow us
to cleverly get uh get a handle on this
uh on these issues
now so actually so let me stay up a
second Now look for the last part I want
to talk a little bit about the work I do
at uh at some of the the
tech companies and so so
um I started doing that when I when I
moved here to the to the GSP and it's
been a great learning experience it's
been very inspiring for for my research
uh and I've I've learned a great deal
we said one
time I was in a meeting where where a
decision was going to be made about
either implementing some change in an
algorithm or not and you know it could
be you could imagine sort of at Airbnb
you decide to make the the way you show
the problem you change the way that you
serve the properties you put videos up
there instead of just pictures or you
put more detailed descriptions of there
and so now they they wanted to know what
the effect was going to be on on rentals
for doing that so they they ran a
randomized experiment
and I suppose and I'm just I'm making up
these numbers suppose that the estimate
was uh was about three dollars per unit
per year or something yeah
that's not particularly big but you
multiply it with a lot of customers that
that there was a there was a big number
but to standard error was two dollars
and so what I said uh the mean well it
kind of it means we're not really so
sure about that uh this three dollars uh
in fact
if there was nothing there if if this
change made no difference whatsoever
that you could easily get an estimate as
big as three
if the standardized is to uh and so the
technical way of saying that is that the
p-value is uh the probability of
getting an estimate that big if the
effect there's nothing there it's about
0.13
and so that's that's
fairly big in fact it's so big that we
would that the technical thermos that we
say it's not statistically significant
but so the question is what do we
actually do with that
and in the
there's a
tendency in the in the academic
literature and kind of also in outside
of that to kind of take that very
seriously kind of often in tables we we
make clear which estimates are
significant kind of we put stars on them
so this is where the the
I was reminded of the story by by Dr
Zeus
those Stars weren't so big they were
really so small you made such a thing
you might think such a thing wouldn't
matter at all but because they had stars
the star belly snitches with break we
are the best kind of snitches on the
beaches
and so
it these things make a big difference
they make a difference in academics
where often there's a tendency not to
publish papers that don't have
significant results but even outside
academics it makes a it makes a big
difference for drug companies when they
do their trials
if things are not significant that can
have a huge impact on their their on
their evaluation and in fact the
um
there was a court case
so in academics what you see is that
people try to change the specification
do some additional analysis find some
way of getting to this getting to the
stars and you can see that by by looking
at the here's a table of kind of the
distribution of all these p-values you
see that people clearly try to find some
way of getting to the promised land
where they they can put stars on this uh
these tables in fact now many journals
now actually use the the
start of machine from Sylvester mcmonkey
McBean and we don't allow people to
actually put stars in these tables to
emphasize the fact that these p-values
are not quite that important and there's
sort of a lot of discussion in the
economic World on on that but it's also
now
outside of academics
where there's a the there was a court
case where the pharmaceutical executive
was in the end convicted by manipulating
p-values so what he did was not actually
calculate them incorrectly but he took a
sample where the strike didn't seem to
have much evidence of any efficacy uh
the p-value was was too big
and he then said well let's look at a
slightly different sample where we throw
out people were really sick because
maybe the drug doesn't do anything for
them and maybe throw out some of the
people were
doing really doing very well and so the
drugs doesn't do anything for them and
for this middle group carefully chosen
there wasn't a fact of with the p-value
of 0.004 and he got into big trouble for
that
so so back to the the question and then
this in this discussion
um so we have this point estimate of two
standard error sort of three is standard
error of two it's not significant does
that actually matter
at some level it it doesn't and the
person in the room was actually in
charge of of making the decision said
well
okay we have a point we have an Ask
number of three so that's that's good so
it's actually seems more likely
that this is actually
doing something in the right direction
so why do we really care about the
standard error
do we care about to stand there
I said that's kind of that was that was
a very astute comment said why why do we
actually care at that point in what way
should the standard error really affect
the decision we're going to make
and so one way to think about it
is that uh
first of all clearly we do care about
the standard errors if we didn't care at
all we could just do really tiny
experiments we could do just take two
people randomize them and so let some
one of them see the new the videos and
the other ones see the pictures and then
make a decision based on that and
clearly that would be that would not be
a sensible thing to do but how do we why
why do we care about the the uncertainty
there now one thing
You could argue yourself maybe be a risk
first if we you know we get a point
estimate of three but maybe it could
just as well be seven as
as minus one and maybe seven would be
great and this would become the biggest
company in the world but minus one they
would be bankrupt and so maybe they
really don't want to take that risk and
so if there's a lot of uncertainty they
wouldn't make these decisions to go
ahead even if on balance it looks like
the the it would be good but that's
that's in many cases that's actually not
really the real reason in many cases
these decisions actually not that big so
you're not really risking the whole
company by uh by making that decision so
what's what's really the reason for
being concerned about the uncertainty
but some level it's because we think
I think in many cases these ideas we're
trying out are bad ideas
most of them are probably bad ideas
and the whole reason we're doing
experimentation is to figure out what
are the good ideas and what are the bad
ideas
but most of the ideas especially kind of
in these more mature companies they've
got to be bad ideas because they're
already reasonably close to doing well
and and being effective and so you can
actually look at that so here's the
a table for my paper by by a set of
session here at Stanford Brad Ephron so
this is not actually from the the tech
companies here this is just medical
experiments he looks at a huge number of
uh of medical experiments it looks at
the ratio of the point estimate and the
standard error the the C statistic I see
that most of them are close to zero
now kind of all these these estimates I
have some uncertainty in them so he can
actually
decompose that
and get an estimate of the distribution
of what is essentially the value of all
these ideas
you kind of you can't think of it I said
each time every idea has some true
intrinsic value
and then we do an experiment to figure
out to estimate that value
and what you see for that distribution
of these these True Values and this is
kind of formatical experiments for drug
trials where the costs are very high so
they they try to really make sure that
these ideas are good before they do any
experiments and still most of these
ideas are bad in the end
and probably in the in a sort of the
experimentation in the the tech
companies it's even worse that kind of
most of these of these ideas are bad but
that's not bad in itself because the
experimentation helps us figure out
which ones are the good ones
but in order to do that
you can't just take the point estimate
you need to combine that
with what you think is actually the
distribution of of the true value of
these ideas
and so you kind of think you can think
of it as every idea sort of comes from
this distribution and now you learn how
how good that particular idea is but you
don't just want to take the experiment
you want to combine that way with what
you thought beforehand and so it takes a
fair amount of evidence
before you should be convinced
that a positive estimate is actually
really indicative of a true positive
effect you should
shade it back shrink it back
towards what you thought before you did
the experiment and if you think
beforehand and all the evidence is there
if you think beforehand that most of the
idea is actually bad
it's good to take a lot of evidence
a lot of precision in the experiment
before you convinced that something is
actually a useful thing to implement
before you should make the decision to
go ahead
and so the reason we care about the
uncertainty
is not
intrinsically that we care about
p-values but what we we care about is
how it changes what we thought before we
did the experiment and before the
experiment we were fairly skeptical that
any of these ideas were very good and
now it takes a fair amount of evidence
to convince us
to take a fair amount of evidence to
convince you that this new idea is
actually a good one
and so that's the if the standard area
is very small that evidence is there if
the standard error is very big that
evidence is not there and you shouldn't
be convinced by that uh that new idea
so so formally the way to think about it
is from a Bayesian perspective we're
making decisions we're not trying
to test hypotheses okay about what what
the truth uh is which is where where
originally these p-values were designed
for them but they're still very useful
it's still the case that in high energy
physics they use p-values to decide
whether they found a new particle or not
and they're they're very careful they
don't want to they're looking for for a
relatively absolute version of the truth
there but that's not the way this the
experimentation is used in many other
settings but we're kind of pretty sure
the things do something we're just not
sure how much they're doing and we want
to update our beliefs to make sure that
we're making uh effective decisions
and so in order kind of for for
the students here to be well prepared to
kind of participate in those decisions
and understand how you actually use data
and what you're trying to get out of
that we kind of need to make sure they
have a fair amount of sophistication and
again it's not about the technical part
in actually doing this analysis but it's
an understanding what the statistics can
actually deliver what we're trying to
get out of these experiments how we
design these experiments and what type
of problems come up in these experiments
so that people can ask the right
questions and not get bamboozled by the
the analysts kind of where we're looking
at this data and we might just say wow
but it's not significant so you
shouldn't do these things you need to
learn how to ask the the right questions
and that's what we're trying to teach
them here
so let me stop here and open it up for
the questions and tech companies where
they're trying to decide whether you
know to change a marketing approach or
to
change something that the feature that
the customers will or not like can you
talk a little bit about how you set up
appropriate experiments like that yeah
so that um that's an incredibly
interesting question it's an incredibly
interesting area these days it's for a
long time
all the experimentation was really based
on the work that had been done in
statistics in the 1920s 1930s 30s people
like Fisher and and Naaman that was kind
of the basis of how drug trials were
done and that was initially the basis
how experimentation was done in the the
tech companies as well but in many cases
the settings are actually very different
one big thing is that where in in drug
trials it's very often very reasonable
to assume that there's no interaction no
interference between the different
individuals that doesn't work in in many
of the social science settings or in the
tech company settings so in a in a drug
trial if I take an aspirin that doesn't
affect whether you have a headache or
not unless I I talk too much but if
you're in a different room you're fine
it doesn't matter for for infectious
diseases and for vaccines and stuff but
in many cases because we can separate
things and we can look at units that
don't don't interact with each other
and say say Airbnb or in the Rideshare
companies interactions are intrinsic to
the whole
um to the company now if
um
if I
um try to get a ride from Uber or Lyft
that affects that takes a particular
driver off the market for a while and so
that affects all the other potential
Riders and so if we do an experiment and
we make it more attractive for a bunch
of individuals to go get rides that
immediately affects all the other
the writers all the other customers in
the market as well and that's true kind
of at Airbnb that's true for all these
companies where that are based on on
individuals interacting in a Marketplace
but these interactions are very
structured and so that leads to a whole
different way of doing experimentation
and so there's kind of a lot of work
there's a lot of work here at the bunch
of people here at the DSP kind of
working with these companies and working
on academic research trying to come up
with with more effective ways of doing
the the experimentation there that just
looks very different from what people
used to do and uh in in medical settings
it's sort of similar to the old adage
about military plans where they say
military plans are worth nothing when
the shooting starts but the planning is
everything so it sounds to me like a lot
of this is a kind of a structure of how
you could go about thinking about all
this data in a plan about trying to
figure out getting a better idea of
where you ought to be going is am I
misunderstanding or is that kind of
close well so some of it uh yes because
some of it would be trying to expose
figure out how we can learn about the
things we're interested in in settings
but we can't do experimentation
some of it is being
figuring out what type of data we really
need and understanding that it may in
some cases be very particular data that
just tell us about the the things we're
interested in again the the
in the video that one of my kids
referred in one of the discussion with
my kids I referred to this paper by the
angress and and Kruger we're interested
in the effect of education on on
earnings and so kind of just comparing
people will go to college with people we
don't go to college
is fraught with difficulties these
people are different in many ways so
it's hard to get causal effects out of
that but what anger San Kruger did was
was figure out some small wrinkle that
changed how people made that decision
namely compulsory schooling laws and in
other work angry cart looked at the at
distance to college again that kind of
just gives you a small wrinkle where it
may affect how people make decisions so
it's kind of somewhat of a combination
of being opportunistic and trying to
look for the the as well as trying to
look for the right data but then in
other places the planning is a much
bigger thing for the for the
experimentation thinking through
how these interactions take place what
the structures on this uh these
interactions whether people interact
purely anonymously through prices or
through the
through other mechanisms can help you
design these experiments effectively
yes
a question I have read in the Press
about a study that was published in
nature in one of its subsidiary journals
it was either something in evolution or
evolution in something and I don't
remember which
but a group in New England decided that
there were 61 genes that determined the
probability of your living to 100. have
you seen that
and
does it follow your rules
no I I have not seen that and so I mean
you know in those those in that type of
setting is so it's again very hard to
figure out how to to separate
correlation from causality now there's
some things you can do you can explore
sometimes you can exploit the fact that
nah
some of the the allocation of DNA is
random from between kids and parents and
so there's been some work trying to
separate out the some of the the genetic
effects from from some of the
environmental effects but so I'm not
familiar with that that particular study
but I I think that it is a little shaky
with some of these things I mean you
know there's also paper that suggests
that and this is based on
data from a while ago because they they
at some point released the information
about who else was nominated for Nobel
prizes and they are they did this
analysis suggesting that people live two
years longer and that that seemed a
little uh that seemed a little shaky
yes
one hand there are the you want to
answer these important questions and you
have limitations on data or natural
experiments that you can actually use as
you were saying to find these little
wrinkles that can help you answer those
questions
now once you find those wrinkles let's
say in the lottery study in
Massachusetts where it's a particular
Lottery where people if I understood
correctly don't have the choice whether
to get the yearly installments or
getting like a um a full payment
then given that you start having all
these constraints
how how do you deal with the limitations
on on whether your results can be
applied to other settings and then how
much of the question are we answering or
is it just a result for a very limited
setting
yeah no that's that's uh that's a very
good uh question and so
so in that particular case clearly we're
not really that interested in in that
particular population
um itself kind of the this was people
who played the lottery in in
Massachusetts and we're interested not
just in play people who played the
lottery but in the general population
we're not not interested in per se and
people in Massachusetts we're interested
in the general U.S population and so so
that clearly comes with some limitations
now but there's some things we can do we
can
see how different these people are who
played the lottery from the general
population in turn because we knew for
these people we had their Social
Security earnings record so we can we
can actually see match them to the rest
of the population see if they're very
different are they different in terms of
the relation between education and
earnings does it look like these these
are really very different people in the
way they they respond and so for in that
particular case there was no much
evidence that these people were very
different not even in terms of earnings
but I would have thought that would be
more stronger correlations there but in
general that that is a big issue and so
we we do worry about the the external
validity of of these studies at the same
time
there is in this literature and I think
might be so uh
sense that we want to focus PRI first of
all on the internal validity we want to
make sure we get incredible estimates at
least for some
well-defined sub-population and then
second we'll worry about how much we can
generalize that and sometimes we go to
find it there's still
there were experiments done in the 60s
for Head Start type programs for Early
Childhood interventions and because
these were done in very small
communities some in in Michigan kind of
and a long time ago in these programs
were quite different from what Head
Start looks like now
but because the and they were very small
they were 200 they're 100 or so kids so
the the evidence from that is clearly
very limited in terms of its relevance
for for decisions that are being made
today and still people keep bringing up
the results from those programs because
that's one of the few times when we did
actually randomize and we saw we know
that at least there it mattered to have
these these Early Childhood Intervention
programs
boy these reunions are amazing this is
just magical uh you know holy mackerel
decision making culture and the tools
that we use I was wondering if you could
share any kinds of uh engagements you've
had regarding the climate problem we
have and just how these uh approaches
are being used to find a way to navigate
out of this this life-threatening issue
climate change and things like that
thanks
yes I don't really have any direct
insights on that one of one of these
things that is actually the most
challenging after winning the Nobel
prizes that you get asked a lot of
things that are outside my direct area
of expertise and so that
it's clearly a huge problem and so a lot
of the methods I I work on kind of I
used in in some of these settings it's
trying to figure out what is the causal
effect of of changing things here on how
the what agriculture is going to look
like what what human development is
going to to look like and we need we
can't do experiments in these cases so
we're going to need to use observational
methods to shed light on these uh these
questions but I haven't done any direct
research on that so I'm hesitant to say
to go much beyond that
[Applause]
foreign